B
WOODWARD.
BOB WOODWARD IS GONNA BE
JOINING US IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS AS WELL.
THAT IS HIM WITH JAMIE.
FIRST OF ALL, TELL US ABOUT THE
AUDIO THAT BOB WOODWARD GOT AS
A RESULT OF HIS FINAL INTERVIEW
IN JULY WITH NOW UNFORTUNATELY
PASSED AWAY GENERAL.
>> JUST FOR CONTEXT, I THINK
OVER HIS CAREER BOB WOULD ROOT
HIS DOWNWARD AND 50 INTERVIEWS
WITH COLIN POWELL.
THESE WERE DONE JULY 12TH, FOR
THE BOOK PERIL, THAT HE JUST
PUBLISHED.
AND THE FIRST ONE WE'RE GONNA
LISTEN TO IS REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY BECAUSE WE'RE
GONNA HEAR GENERAL POWELL TALK
ABOUT HIS HEALTH FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
HE TOLD BOB WOODWARD ABOUT HIS
HEALTH.
>> I GOT ADMITTED TO THE
HOSPITAL ABOUT 2 3 TIMES THIS
WEEK.
I'VE GOT MULTIPLE MYELOMA
CANCER.
I GOT PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
BUT OTHERWISE I'M FINE.
>> OH NO!
I AM SO SORRY.
>> DON'T FEEL SORRY.
THAT IS OKAY.
I WILL BE FINE.
I'M 85 YEARS OLD.
>> I HAVEN'T LOST A DAY IN LIFE
SPOUTING THESE CHANGES --
>> WELL THAT'S GREAT.
YOU HAVE NEVER LOST A DAY OF
LIFE.
I MEAN, THINK OF THE ACTIVIST,
GENERALS FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE, NOW ORACLE, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> AND TYPICAL SELF
DEPRECATING.
IT'S NOTHING SHORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY.
HERE HE WAS SUFFERING FROM
MULTIPLE MYELOMA, AND REALLY
DEADLY BLOOD CANCER.
AND PARKINSON'S, IN THE MIDDLE
OF COVID.
AND HE IS SAYING, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT ME.
BOB WOODWARD WENT ON LATER IN
THE INTERVIEW.
WE'RE GONNA PLAY ONE MORE
SECTION OF THIS AUDIO INTERVIEW
WHERE WOODWARD ASKED GENERAL
POWELL, WHO IS YOUR GREATEST
HERO OF ALL THE PEOPLE YOU'VE
MET?
AND THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHO WAS THE GREATEST MAN,
WOMAN OR PERSON YOU HAVE EVER
KNOWN?
NOT JUST AIR LEADER, NOT
NECESSARILY, BUT A HEROIC
PERSON.
>> THE MORAL COMPASS, THE SENSE
OF PROPRIETY, THE SENSE OF THE
TRUTH MATTERS --
WHO IS THAT AN ALL OF YOUR LIFE?
WHO?
>> --
[INAUDIBLE]
>> GOOD FOR YOU.
>> SHE WAS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S FOR 15 YEARS --
AND SHE WENT THROUGH A LOT.
>> SHE WAS ALWAYS THERE FOR ME
AND TOLD ME THAT'S NOT A GOOD
IDEA.
SHE WAS USUALLY RIGHT.
>> THAT IS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
I WONDER HOW MANY TIMES POWELL
SAID THAT.
WHERE ARE GONNA HAVE MORE OF
WOODWARD'S EXTRAORDINARY
INTERVIEW WITH COLIN POWELL
FROM THE SUMMER.
BUT THERE IS A PART OF JUST
WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE INTERVIEW,
POWELL HEARS GENERAL POWELL ON
THE PHONE AND HE SAYS ONE 2ND,
I AM ON THE PHONE.
AND HE SAYS TO WOODWARD, SHE
NEVER REALLY LIKED MY TALKING
TO YOU.
[LAUGHS]
>> ALL MAZEN AMAZING WOMAN.
I KNOW HER.
YOU KNOW HER.
SHE'S REALLY AN AMAZING WOMAN.
THE JOURNALIST BOB WOODWARD IS
JOINING US RIGHT NOW.
HE'S THE CO-AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK, " BARREL " IN NEW YORK
TIMES.
NUMBER ONE BESTSELLER.
BOB, IT'S AMAZING STUFF THAT
YOU --
THIS WAS YOUR LAST INTERVIEW
WITH GENERAL COLIN POWELL.
50 WAS JAYME REPORTS THAT YOU
CONDUCTED OVER THE LAST 3
DECADES.
WITH STRUCK YOU AS A REFLECTED
ON HIS OWN CAREER, AND WHAT
ALSO STRUCK YOU ABOUT HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE STATE OF OUR
COUNTRY?
>> WELL WOLF, FIRST OF ALL, HE
WAS SO INDEPENDENT MINDED.
HE WAS INDEED THE SOLDIER, BUT
AT THE FIRST GULF WAR IN 1991,
WHEN THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
STEVE, HE WAS PUSHING AGAINST.
HE WAS THE RELUCTANT WARRIOR.
AND MANY TIMES I DISCUSSED WITH
HIM THIS PARADOX OF BEING THE
RELUCTANT WARRIOR, AND BEING
THE NUMBER ONE MILITARY
OFFICER.
AND HE SAID, JUST 3 MONTHS AGO,
HE SAID, NO, I DID NOT LIKE A
WAR.
I DO NOT LIKE BEING A WARRIOR.
THIS IS BECAUSE HE HAVE BEEN IN
VIETNAM.
HE KNEW THE UGLY SIDE OF WAR.
HE KNEW THAT WAR HAD TO BE THE
LAST RESORT, AND SO, WHEN IT
CAME TO TIME, AND THIS AGAIN IS
THIS CYCLE IN HIS LIFE, HE IS
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR GEORGE
W. BUSH.
AND THEY INVADED AFGHANISTAN,
AND THAT WAS SUPPORTED WIDELY,
BUT THEN AROUND THE VERGE
INVADING IRAQ, AND AGAIN POWELL
SURFACES AS THE VOICE OF DO WE
HAVE TO DO THIS?
IS THERE ANOTHER OPTION?
AND IN THE END, HE MADE HIS
CASE, BUT IN RETROSPECT AND
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH HIM,
HE WOULD SAY I DIDN'T MAKE THE
CASE STRONG ENOUGH.
I SHOULD HAVE MADE IT STRONGER.
AND HE CAME TO THE VIEW THAT
THE IRAQ WAR WAS PROBABLY NOT
NECESSARY, SO THIS IS A MAN IN
ALL OF THESE ROLES.
AND AGAIN, EXPRESSING THAT
CONVICTION THAT WE HAVE TO
PROTECT THE COUNTRY, WE WILL GO
TO WAR, WE WILL KILL THE ENEMY,
IF NECESSARY.
BUT WE WANT TO AVOID THAT AT
ALL COST.
>> WE HAVE THAT RELUCTANT
WARRIOR CLIP FROM YOUR
INTERVIEW, THE AUDIO.
AND I WANT TO PLAY IT FOR OUR
VIEWERS NOW.
STANDBY.
>> THE RELUCTANT WARRIOR?
WHATEVER THAT IS --
IT'S TRUE.
THE I AM A RELUCTANT WARRIOR.
I DON'T LIKE WARS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE A WARRIOR.
BUT REMEMBER THE OTHER THING
THAT IS WELL KNOWN ABOUT ME.
AND THAT IS I WILL DO
EVERYTHING I CAN TO --
>> YOU'VE GOT THAT POWELL
DOCTRINE THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
WAS SO SO POWERFUL DURING THE
FIRST GULF WAR.
FIRST YOU'RE GONNA CUT IT OFF
THEN YOU'RE GONNA KILL IT.
BUT HE HAD AN EXCELLENT
STRATEGY IN MIND.
AND THE U.S. PULLED OUT OF THE
MIDDLE EAST VERY QUICKLY AFTER
DEPLOYING HALF 1 MILLION TROOPS
IN THE AREA.
YOU AND I REMEMBER THAT, RIGHT
BOB?
>> WE DO.
AND THAT WAS --
I TALK TO HIM IN JUST 3 MONTHS
AGO ABOUT THAT WAR, AND OF
COURSE, IT WAS A WAR WHICH HAD
VERY LOW CASUALTIES.
137 U.S. SERVICEMEN KILLED
INITIALLY, AND WE DISCUSSED
THAT.
AND HE SAID HE REALLY CAN'T GET
OVER HOW SUCCESSFUL IT WAS AS A
WAR.
AND OF COURSE, IT DECIMATED
SADDAM HUSSEIN'S ARMY IN IRAQ,
BUT NOT ENOUGH, AND NOT FULLY.
AND THEN, THAT CYCLE CAME BACK
AGAIN, WHILE HE WAS SECRETARY
OF STATE AND RESISTING THIS.
SO HE IS GOING TO BE REMEMBERED
RIGHTFULLY.
HE IS SOMEBODY WHO STOOD HIS
GROUND, AS KANE WOULD SAY, WHEN
I INTERVIEWED 3 MONTHS AGO, I
AM --
HIS WIFE CALLED OUT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
HE SAID, I'M ON THE PHONE, AND
THEN HE DID TURN JIMMY.
AND SAY SHE DOESN'T WANT ME.
SHE DOESN'T LIKE ME TALKING TO
YOU, BUT HERE WE ARE.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE WAS GOING TO
TALK ANYWAY, EVEN THOUGH HE WAS
SAYING, DON'T DO THIS.
SO THIS WAS A SINGULAR PERSON
WHO BROUGHT --
A GO TO THE REALLY INTERESTING
POWERFUL PART OF HIS STORY,
AFTER HE LEFT BEING CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEFS AND PUBLISHED
HIS MEMOIR, EVERYONE THOUGHT HE
WAS GONNA RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
AND I SPENT A LONG TIME TALKING
TO HIM AND HIS AIDES, AND
REALIZE THAT BEFORE HE
ANNOUNCED HE WASN'T GONNA RUN,
THAT HE WAS NOT GONNA RUN
BECAUSE IN WAR, HE ALWAYS
WANTED TO SEND ENOUGH TO
GUARANTEE FULL SUCCESS.
AND HE REALIZED IN POLITICS,
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE OF
SUCCESS, AND I THINK THAT IS
LARGELY WHY HE PULLED BACK AND
DID NOT RUN.
>> I THINK ALMA BASED ON
EVERYTHING I REMEMBER AT THE
TIME, SHE WAS ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT HIS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT,
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN.
I THINK SHE CLEARLY FIELD AS
LIGHT POTENTIALLY COULD BE
ENDANGERED.
THAT'S WHAT I REMEMBER HEARING
AT THE TIME I SUSPECT HE DID,
AND AS WELL AS CITED AFTER RUN
FOR PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IN THE INTERVIEW, THIS LAST
INTERVIEW ON JULY HE DID WITH
YOU, BOB, HE STRUCK AN
OPTIMISTIC TONE, TELLING YOU
ABOUT HIS HEALTH PROBLEMS.
HE TRULY APPRECIATED EVERYTHING
LIFE HAD TO OFFER TO HIM, A
CHILD OF EMIGRANTS GROWING UP
IN THE SOUTH BRONX.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN BECOMING
ONE DAY CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS OF STAFF AND SECRETARY
OF STATE.
>> YEAH, HE REALIZED THAT.
AND HE WAS AGAIN RELUCTANT WHEN
HE WAS OFFERED THE JOB OF
SECRETARY OF BY GEORGE W. BUSH.
BUT HE REALIZED, AND AGAIN,
THIS IS A MILITARY TRADITION,
WHEN THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF
ASKS, YOU SERVE.
AND SO, HE SERVED AS SECRETARY
OF STATE, AND AS HE TOLD YOU,
AS ENDORSEMENT OF THE
INTELLIGENCE FOR THE IRAQ WAR